oh
not gonna lie i've kind of missed this
[Music]
he's back christopher eccleston
is returning to the role of the ninth
doctor for the first time since the end
of series one
it's nice to have good news in 2020
seriously now
a couple things to clarify for anyone
who is not already aware of the news
this at this point in time is him
returning to big
finish so this is audio adventures that
we're talking about
that does not preclude him from ever
taking on the role
in a visual medium again some people are
already throwing around the idea that
maybe this means he'll be
you know prepared to make some kind of
appearance when we get to the 60th
anniversary
in a couple years but let's not jump the
gun all right
this alone is a big deal this alone is a
big step so let's let's not
jumble our heads thinking about oh what
else will this
let's deal with what we've actually got
right now
because what we've got is great
so if you are a bit like me
this might seem a little bit
disappointing or if you're a bit like i
was
a few years ago before i started getting
into big finish because
there are plenty of doctor who fans who
really only watch the show
and that's totally valid honestly most
of the time
that's how i am i don't get into
ancillary
materials in other mediums you know if
something is
a film or a tv series i don't get into
comic books and novels and all this
other
stuff i just generally don't the big
exception that i do make at this point
is doctor who big finish and i think a
lot of it has to do with the nature of
the audio because
it's not me reading on a you know
somebody writing these characters and i
have to plug in
you know my memory of how they would
have delivered the lines or in the case
of a comic i'm not watching
often photo referencing creating a weird
uncanny valley effect
you know recreations of these characters
that really throws me off when it comes
to comics
but instead i just get to hear it and i
can imagine what it looks like
very easily if i get to hear that
doctor deliver those lines and if you're
not into big finish
maybe this will be a leaping on point
for you because i do need to do a video
sort of like
how to get into big finish at some point
down the line
but this i like speaking as someone
who has a hard time getting into
expanded universe ancillary material
big finish is terrific and it's great
for getting into no matter what doctor
you
like if that doctor has stories in big
finish
they're probably going to be worth
seeking out i'm not going to say there's
no duds but
these things are lovingly made and when
they fail they rarely
fail harshly so
the pairing of eccleston and big finish
this is this is a big get
and while it may require some people to
have to step out of their normal media
comfort zone in order to get some more
ecosystem i think it's going to be a
trip
worth taking there are a few things to
keep in mind though
the first is he is not going to be
appearing in the time lord victorious
which is a big
multi-platform story involving numerous
doctors that i've talked about
previously he is not appearing as part
of that now the character of the ninth
doctor
is that was confirmed some time ago and
i certainly had
hoped that eccleston would be involved
in that but that is not going to be the
case so i've seen some people
like get that mixed up so be clear about
that
the ninth doctor's part in that story is
probably going to be either in novels or
comics or if he appears in audio it's
going to be with a sound alike which
they have done things along those lines
before
uh for small scale things with the ninth
doctor in audio
but eccleston himself will not take part
in that and i suspect that's largely a
matter of timing
because we we have a timeline on how
this came together i'll kind of come
back to that and
address that more specifically a little
bit later but
at the time that he started talking
seriously with big finish about coming
back
time the time lord victorious would have
already been probably well into
production
because i mean the time frame of how
long it takes to produce a novel of
comic
audio adventures etc the time scale is
different for each of those but trying
to coordinate all those together
that's a massive undertaking and
everything was probably already locked
in
by the time ecclestone started
expressing an interest in getting
involved and trying to slot him into a
machine like that with so many moving
parts
it probably was just never going to be
reasonable that doesn't mean time lord
victorious won't be good doesn't mean it
won't be worth looking into
but it does mean don't expect him there
because what it has been said is that we
are going to start getting audios of
the ninth doctor in 2021 actually we
have a specific
release month that is may of 2021
because big finish
is taking pre-orders for the box sets
which brings me to another thing worth
mentioning
again if you're not familiar with big
finish this is worth um
specifying as well big finish has
until recently come in a few different
flavors they started out with what was
called the monthly range
a completely self-contained doctor who
story
released once a month with kind of a
rotation of the various doctors who they
had access to which initially
was um peter davidson's fifth doctor
colin baker's six doctors
um sylvester mccoy's seventh doctor and
then not too much later
i'm getting paul mcgann's eighth doctor
in they
would later start doing box sets as well
for
various things they would do box sets
for spin-offs when they did things like
the war doctor the war master
missy river song and so forth they've
also done
narrative box sets where it's a
continuing story across
multiple um entries and that's where you
get things like
dark eyes now it was announced i
think it was either earlier this year i
think or
late last year i think it was earlier
this year that big finish is going to be
discontinuing the monthly range and now
it's only going to be the box sets which
is something i personally have mixed
feelings about i at the end of the day i
prefer a really
well-crafted self-contained story more
than something
stretched out in segments over time and
even when i get box sets
it's more often than not it's the more
self-contained stories within that box
set that i tend to like more than the
others
but that's a personal taste thing what
it does
mean is that box sets
tend to be a bit on the pricey side
more often than not and what we have
announced is four
box sets for christopher eccleston now
they're available for pre-order
and they've currently got them at 20
bucks a pop that's
cheap for their box sets but it does
mean you're going to drop 80 bucks for
the whole thing
now they're right now labeling it as
ninth doctor adventures
which this this is going to be
a bit of guesswork on my part i would be
inclined to say it
probably means that there isn't going to
be a continuous story across
all the box sets i only say that because
generally when they've used the word
adventures
in box sets they've been more
self-contained at least to within
that box set like so for instance i have
fourth doctor adventures as
a box set and there are some stories
within that box that are completely
self-contained
and but there is an overarching story
running across it but it is complete
within that box set
so that's what i would expect and i
would be
surprised if they're using that moniker
if they do something
more of a grand miniseries into a maxi
series like they did with the
aforementioned dark guys i don't expect
that that'll be the case
now i said i would come back to the time
frame and
this this was the part of this story
that
warmed my heart the most and i do want
to be sure to
highlight this specifically so when big
finish made this announcement
their um chairman jason
hey uh ellery which i hope i didn't
butcher that but whatever
he said quote i first talked to
christopher about returning to the role
of the doctor at the gallifrey one
convention in february
this year christopher said he was
enjoying meeting the fans and
was pleased that his doctor was
remembered so fondly he indicated he
would be open to discussing
a project with big finish
that gave me so much joy because
i was at gallifrey one
i met christopher eccleston he signed
the picture that i had taken with him
i got to tell him myself
what his doctor means to me now i'm not
going to say that i am
personally responsible for him taking up
the role again that's for
other people to say but i am saying that
i
got to be there and feel the vibe and
contribute to the amount of
outpouring of love for his work and for
what he did with the part
i was there on the last day of the
convention when
everyone that they were allowed to cram
into the main hall got there and we all
sang happy birthday to christopher
eccleston because the last day of the
convention was his birthday and he said
with so much sincerity that this was his
best birthday ever
the love was real and i'm so glad that
he felt that because i
i would imagine given his complicated
relationship historically with doctor
who given
you know some of the clashes he had
behind the scenes during his tenure
there
and then you know sort of what we've
learned more about where he was
you know as a person and things he was
dealing with at that point in time which
is also something i've talked about
before
it's understandable that it was
difficult for him to consider coming
back to this role because
it's a role that involved a lot of
baggage
for him and i i it does seem very much
and i
certainly would like to think that the
fans
making it unambiguous that we love what
he did
and we would love to see more of him
helped alleviate whatever lingering
doubts there might have been
welcome back christopher we are so happy
you're here
and i don't know what you've got in
store to us but i do know one thing
it's going to be fantastic
what are your thoughts on this whatever
they are drop something down the
comments
let's talk about it usual stuff to do
you know what it is everyone does it i
have a patreon that was kind of
important it's what's
currently covering my bills and in
addition to that i have
merch and social media and a podcast and
a bunch of other stuff
links in the description check it out or
don't
at the end of the day you are the
council
and i am just running the meetings and
until next time this council
has adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
bye